with such a large cast 1883 will
undoubtedly have you scratching your
head and wondering do i know them
stay tuned to find out where you've seen
or heard the cast of 1883 before
sam elliott's career is a long one and
if you're a fan of pretty much any genre
you're likely to have seen him around
the actor is no stranger to playing
western heroes like shea brennan an old
cowboy haunted by the recent death of
his family to smallpox who helps guide a
wagon train of german settlers north to
start a new life these germans got to
learn to hold their own thomas
they won't survive the trip
none of us will
elite got his start playing very minor
roles in the 60s and the 70s in cowboy
classics like the way west and butch
cassidy and the sundance kid
he enjoyed a steady career and
eventually established himself as a
leading man in westerns like the quick
and the dead gettysburg and tombstone
where he played virgil erp brother to
legendary gunslinger wyatt
the latter was released shortly after
the film wyatt earp starring yellowstone
star kevin costner and proved the
financial winner of course he was also
well known for playing unique supporting
parts in movies like the big lebowski
where his experience as a cowboy served
him well when he played a mysterious
stranger who narrates the film he also
appeared in key roles in a pair of early
marvel superhero movies as well
in ghost rider he plays the titular
hero's predecessor a demonic cowboy on a
flaming horse
while in the hulk he played general ross
a role he would eventually hand over to
william hurt
if you hadn't paid attention to the
press before the premiere of 1883 you
might not recognize the actor playing
james dutton at all even though he's
arguably the biggest name on the series
played by superstar country crooner tim
mcgraw the singer and part-time thespian
donned a scruffy beard and dirty hat to
play the original patriarch of the
dutton family heading north to found
what will eventually become the dutton
ranch
mcgraw was already a hit country singer
when he made his acting debut in an
episode of the jeff boxworthy show in
1997 and over the two decades that
followed he appeared in movies like
flick up friday night lights and
tomorrowland
however if you recognize him it's almost
certainly from his musical career where
the three-time grammy award winner has
become a superstar with singles like
it's your love just to see you smile and
live like you were dying
he's also the husband of fellow country
sensation singer faith hill his 1883
co-star who plays his on-screen wife as
series creator taylor sheridan explained
to deadline mcgraw first played james
dutton in a flashback sequence in an
early fourth season episode of
yellowstone which led to paramount
immediately asking for a spin-off based
around mcgraw's character
1883 marks mcgraw's first significant
acting role in a series and he leads
1883 with a cool swagger
country singer and occasional actor
faith hill has had an even shorter
hollywood career than her husband tim
mcgraw but is every bit as talented in
front of the camera as she is behind a
microphone
her first major hollywood appearance
came in the 2004 nicole kidman thriller
the stepford wives
she had a bigger role in the 2017 film
dixieland before she joined the cast of
1883.
you lied idea didn't i what kind of a
woman drinks coffee i can't wait to hear
this lecture on womanhood
like her husband faith hill is far
better known for her singing career
regardless of whether you're a fan of
country music or not you're likely to
recognize some of her many hits which
include the 1998 country single this
kiss which had crossover success as a
mainstream chart topper or the 1999
single breathe
she also contributes memorable songs to
movie soundtracks like michael bay's
pearl harbor the 2000 holiday feature dr
seuss how the grinch stole christmas and
the disney animated classic lilo and
stitch in 2007 she became the voice of
nbc's sunday night football theme and
sang the national anthem at the 2009
super bowl the los angeles times notes
that she even performed at the obama
white house in 2010 and at the rock and
roll hall of fame induction ceremony for
abba that same year after nearly a
decade off from recording she released
the rest of your life in 2017 an album
made with her husband tim mcgraw
actress isabelle may was not much older
than the 17 year old elsa dutton when
she landed the part in 1883 according to
an interview with town and country she
was promised to roll by series creator
taylor sheridan after being turned down
for a part in another series and never
expected it to come so soon after her
rejection
if you recognize may you probably know
her from just one or two roles as she
does not have a long hollywood career
with her first part only coming in 2018
however since appearing as a background
character in the indie drama age of
summer the actress has had key parts in
several high-profile series
audiences may recognize isabelle from
her recurring role on young sheldon as
veronica duncan the on-again off-again
love interest of sheldon's older brother
georgie as that role wound down she
began stirring in the netflix original
series alexa and katie in the title role
of katie cooper the streaming teen drama
series followed may as the best friend
of a young girl diagnosed with cancer
following her casting in 1883 the actor
has secured roles in several movies
including the netflix romantic comedy i
want you back and a teen comedy called
the moon and back
actor lamonica garrett may be best known
to comic book fans for his role as the
anti-monitor a cosmic dc comics villain
who made appearances across five
different connecting superhero shows on
the cw
garrett as the anti-monitor would
feature in the flash supergirl arrow
dc's legends of tomorrow and batwoman
during the epic crossover event crisis
on infinite earths
in 1883 he placed thomas an agent with
the pinkerton detective agency a
real-life private security group with a
complicated history
garrett's biggest role before the new
paramount plus western spin-off was as
mike ritter the secret service agent
responsible for kiefer sutherland's
president tom kirkman in the first two
seasons of the drama designated survivor
beginning with some guest appearances on
shows like ncis suits and csi miami he
found a regular recurring role in sons
of anarchy as deputy sheriff kane
he also appears as adonis in the hulu
series the hot wives of las vegas a
satirical send-up of soap opera reality
shows just before taking on the role of
thomas in 1883 he appeared in an episode
of brooklyn 99 and had a recurring part
in the oprah winfrey network drama
delilah
he also appears as commander bill cox in
the amazon original drama the
terminalist about a navy seal who
struggles with his return home after a
covert mission gone wrong
joseph is played by german actor mark
rissman who got his start in a string of
german films however audiences stateside
should know him well from his small but
important role in the hbo fantasy series
game of thrones where he played harry
strickland head of house strickland he
appears in the battle of king's landing
where he clashes directly with jon snow
davos tyrion and their armies in any
event you are most welcome here in
king's landing captain strickland
we look forward to fighting on your
behalf your grace
audiences may also recognize risman as
wilhelm gortzman from the man in the
high castle however it may have been
wristman's role in the film overlord
that secured him the part as gortzman as
he played the part of scherzer a twisted
nazi officer operating in occupied
france
as ennis actor eric nelson is set up for
a significant role on one of streaming
television's most talked about new
dramas it could wind up being a
career-making performance for the actor
who's mostly made a name for himself as
a guest star on shows like ncis the
blacklist the following and bluebloods
nelson may be most recognized however
from when he made regular appearances in
the popular soap opera all my children
in 2013.
there he played the character of aj
chandler across more than 40 episodes
he's also had recurring roles in web
series that include the bay and fracture
but 1883 is his first time appearing in
the main cast of a major network series
james landry a bear is no stranger to
westerns though it's been a while for
him since he suited up in a cowboy hat
in 2012 he appeared in an episode of
neo-western longmire and had a
three-episode stint a year later as a
cowboy in the artificial wild west theme
park of westworld
he recently starred in not-so-wild west
and sunset cowboys where he played a
hollywood cowboy stuntman fans of
stranger things may recognize a bear as
the character of axel from the series
second season the mohawked member of the
gang that eleven hides out with while in
pittsburgh he later appeared in taken
the television adaptation of the popular
liam neeson-led film series where he got
his first shot as a member of a series
main cast
crime drama fans may recall his part as
miles hewitt in the frank darabont event
series mob city
other memorable parts for a bear include
playing a former soviet officer in
marvel's agent carter and a small role
as clem in quentin tarantino's 2019 film
once upon a time in hollywood
based on a real-life historical figure
the character of us marshall jim
courtright is played by hollywood legend
billy bob thornton
his well-known roles are many and though
his only oscar is for his work as a
screenwriter he's received his share of
recognition for his work in front of the
camera too
until recently however he may have been
best known for his role as carl childers
in the 1996 drama slingblade or even for
his short-lived relationship with
angelina jolie
however a string of high-profile
prestige tv roles have made him famous
with a whole new generation beginning
with his role as serial killer and
sociopath lauren malvo in the 2014
television spin-off of fargo
your problem is you spent your whole
life thinking there are rules
there aren't
from there thornton took the lead role
in the amazon original series goliath a
legal drama where he played billy
mcbride a downtrodden lawyer looking to
resurrect his career
you may also recognize thornton as the
titular bad santa in the 2003 film and
its 2016 sequel or his roles in movies
like the remake of bad news bears the
sports drama friday night lights and the
acclaimed monsters ball
on television he's had guest appearances
on the big bang theory and performed
voice work on american dad king of the
hill and cat dog
not much is known of little audie rick
the newcomer to hollywood who has taken
on the role of the first john dutton the
great grandfather to yellowstone
patriarch and namesake to the character
played by kevin costner
with the only earlier part to his credit
on imdb being a star wars fan film that
saw him play a young luke skywalker 1883
seems to mark his professional acting
debut
whatever the case the child actor now
appears on one of the biggest new
streaming releases of the year should
the yellowstone prequel series run for
more than a few seasons fans may get to
see rick and his character john dutton
grow up on screen
sam visits the wagon train to trade
along with a small group of native
americans but quickly develops a budding
romance with elsa how do you say my name
[Music]
lined in with the yellow hair
sam may be a newcomer to 1883 in episode
vii but martin sensemeyer should look
familiar for fans of the show's parents
series
the actor appeared on yellowstone as
martin a swim instructor helping casey's
wife monica recover from her injuries
after being attacked at her son's school
the pair develop a romance of their own
although monica quickly breaks it off it
remains to be seen if sam is an ancestor
of martins but anything is possible
given the show's many connections
aside from yellowstone western fans may
remember since meyer for his role as the
young native american warrior red
harvest in the 2016 remake of the
magnificent seven
he also had a recurring role as wahnatan
another native american warrior in
season two of the sci-fi series
westworld
though you'd be forgiven for not
recognizing the actor as he was covered
in thick white body paint for the part
outside of those series sensemeyer
appeared in the liberator as sergeant
coldfoot and in an episode of fbi where
he played a man forced to take the law
into his own hands after his daughter
goes missing
colton an old friend of wade and ennis
joins the wagon train in episode 6.
colton is played by noah legross who has
a short but impressive resume
before joining the series legross
headlined the 2019 horror film the beach
house as randall one half of a young
couple who goes on vacation only to find
a frightening older couple threatening
their lives
1883 isn't the only streaming series
legross has appeared on as his first
major role was a regular spot on the
netflix teen drama the get down
there he played the character of thor a
young graffiti artist and love interest
to jaden smith's dizzy even if you don't
recognize legross you may be familiar
with his family lineage as his father is
actor james legross
the elder legross had a memorable
ongoing role in the fx series justified
as wade messer a drug addict who can't
seem to keep his nose clean and keeps
causing trouble
according to britannica the character of
charles goodnight is based on a
real-life historical figure a famous
rancher and former texas ranger who
roamed the west throughout the late
1800s
in 1883 he appears as an old friend of
shea brennans and helps the convoy fight
off cattle raiders
when they part goodnight remarks it's
not likely that they will see each other
again
however given the actor who plays him
it's not hard to imagine goodnight
turning up again
that's because goodnight is played by
the creator of both yellowstone and 1883
taylor sheridan
yellowstone fans will remember him in
the recurring role of horse trainer
travis wheatley and he is also well
known for his part in sons of anarchy as
david hale as an actor sheridan has also
had a regular role in veronica mars
where he played danny boyd as well as
small parts and episodes of star trek
enterprise csi nypd blue and ncis los
angeles
but it's as a screenwriter that sheridan
has had most of his success as he not
only created yellowstone in 1883 but
also the jeremy renner drama mayor of
kingstown
he was nominated for an academy award
for his screenplay for 2016's hell or
high water and wrote the action drama
sicario
playing claire dutton sister to
protagonist james don olivieri appears
in a new kind of role for her
claire is prim and proper not used to
the rough living of a woman on the
western frontier
james your children are feral
absolutely feral
hello claire
previous parts for the actor include her
stint on house of lies as monica talbot
the career-minded consultant and
sexually aggressive ex-wife to iron man
star don cheadle
speaking of superheroes olivieri once
voiced iron man's girlfriend pepper
potts in the animated series avengers
earth's mightiest heroes and had a
recurring part in a hero's webisode
series in 2009
she's also played several law
enforcement roles in shows like lucifer
secrets and lies and rosewood
in 2017 she appeared in the cbs drama
seal team alongside david boreanaz as
amy nelson a private security specialist
working out of afghanistan in the series
first season
just before 1883 she had a recurring
role in the miniseries the hot zone
anthrax a scripted drama on national
geographic
though her 1883 character doesn't last
beyond the first pair of premier
episodes
claire dutton was the unforgettable type
of character that audiences love to hate
and it would be a shame if that were the
last we saw of her
romani immigrant noemi plays more of a
background role through the first half
of 1883 season 1 but slowly becomes one
of its most important characters
lost and alone after the death of her
husband she charms and romances the
pinkerton agent thomas and the two are
now one of the show's best couples
a newcomer to the screen actress
gratiella brancusi plays the widow
noemie in her first professional acting
role a former marketing executive for
the la based theater company the actors
gang she's recently switched careers to
become an actor and is already
impressing audiences as the haunted
noemi
according to the sun audiences familiar
with the world of celebrity gossip may
recognize her as the now ex-wife of
shawshank redemption star tim robbins
but based on her performance so far in
1883 she's very likely about to become a
better known name on her own merits
episode 6 boring the devil sees a gruff
short-tempered cook join the caravan
the appropriately nicknamed cookie is
hired by thomas to be their resident
cook and is paid handsomely to make sure
everyone in the group has good meals on
their journey
however his sour mood riles up the ire
of margaret dutton when he curses in
front of her young son he also tends to
defy shea and james which gets him into
trouble playing the role of cookie is an
actor that fans of taylor sheridan's
other works will surely be familiar with
james jordan jordan appeared in the
sheridan pen film wind river and in both
of sheridan's two other recent hits the
1883 parent series yellowstone and the
paramount plus crime drama mayor of
kingstown
in yellowstone jordan plays similarly
harassable livestock agent sergeant
steve hendon who works under casey
dutton and gets into trouble more than
once due to his dim-wittedness and mayor
of kingstown jordan plays the recurring
role of ed simmons the tyrannical
corrections officer who became a target
during a massive prison riot he also had
an ongoing role as tim foyle on veronica
mars and made several one-off
appearances in shows like the mentalist
justified fargo and csi
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one